hey guys got some training footage for
you this was primarily an upper body
pressing day started off with some light
rows just to get everything warmed up
and then on to some behind the neck
pushed jerks this is 275 for a triple
this was actually a PR the presses
themselves well the jerks themselves
felt pretty easy as you can see but I
haven't done these in a while so I had
issues catching the first rep I caught
too far forward second rep I caught too
far back and the third rep you can't see
it but I just said [ __ ] it and dropped
it then onto bench 405 for two solid
rips really not too much to say about
that since I haven't been training
consistently I'm pretty happy with how
this double at 405 felt but obviously
I'm expecting a lot more of myself as I
get back into a groove after that I
followed it up with some Close Grip
supposed to be explosive presses with no
leg drive the intent to move the bar
fast matters more than the bar speed
itself first two reps were fast last one
slowed down a little but since I can't
use a leg driving I'm pretty good at
using leg drive doing this without any
leg drive whatsoever and also the close
grip for a longer range of motion helps
me build some strength off the chest
finish it up with some cable flies and
some tricep extensions and that was that
now by popular demand the beers I've
been drinking recently this was a
Rochford tin I shouldn't have to say too
much about this one because it's
absolutely world-class it was the first
time I'd ever had one actually and it
did not disappoint me it definitely
lived up to its reputation probably the
best quad I've ever had these were two
more recent ones the American Beauty
from dogfish that was my wife's that's a
double IPA it was I mean I suppose it
was good for an IPA
I'm not too much of an IPA drinker and
the terrible by unibrow
that was mine it was it was a solid quad
if nothing outstanding but I'm the fan
of the brewery and I'm a fan of quads in
general really it's just hard to go
wrong with a good quad so I'd give that
one eight out of ten I definitely drink
it again
and since quads tend to be quite pricey
for the price I'm definitely not going
to complain about it it was a solid
beverage I did not get any video from my
recent deadlift day and that's really
nothing to complain about because it was
pretty terrible deadlift is the most
temperamental lift for me my squat and
bench tend to be fairly consistent but
my deadlift fluctuates a lot so we're
just not really going to talk about that
deadlift day and that's okay I'll get my
groove back soon that's about it for
this video guys thanks for watching if
you haven't subscribed already please do
so like the video and until next time
smash some weight and drinks and beer
all right have a good one guys